If you're a Windows user, you're
probably familiar with working at the
command line of a Windows computer. You
would go to the start menu and look for
cmd.exe, for example. The process is
very similar in Linux. You'll be
starting an application such as
Terminal, Xterm, or something that's
very similar to get you to the command
prompt of the Linux device. If you're
running Mac OS, you'll find that the
commands that we use here in Linux and
the commands available in Mac OS are
very similar to each other. You should
be able to use almost all of these
commands in your Mac OS terminal screen.
Although Mac OS is derived from a Unix
version known as Berkeley Software
Distribution or BSD. This video will
focus on commands that are native to
Linux. If you're not currently using
Linux, this would be a great time to
learn about virtualization on a desktop.
For example, if you're running Windows,
you might want to download the latest
version of VMware Workstation or Virtual
Box so that you can virtualize Linux on
your current desktop. having a virtual
machine of Linux that you can use
instead of restarting your computer into
a separate Linux partition and then
restarting your computer to go back to
Windows. You can instead run Linux on
the desktop of your computer. And as I
go through this video today, you'll see
me using Linux, but it's really Linux
running inside of a VM. As we go through
these command prompts today, I'll give
you an overview of how that command
operates. But if you'd like more
information about that particular
command, you can go to the command
prompt and use the man command. This
stands for manual. So if you wanted to
look at the manual for the grep command,
you would use man space grep and read
all about the details of the gp command.
There's usually a lot of information
stored on these man pages because this
is the documentation for that utility.
So once you've read through the entire
manual page for that command, you'll
know every possible option available to
run that
utility. Here's my Iuntu desktop. This
is the front end that we're going to use
to run these Linux commands today, but
you can run any Linux distribution you'd
like. And these commands will
functionally be the same across all of
those different distributions. You can
see that I have a terminal that I've
already pinned to my lefthand menu bar,
but I can go all the way down to the
list of applications on this computer
and simply search for the word terminal.
And if I do that, it will list out all
of the available options. On this
distribution, I have two different
terminals to choose from. The standard
terminal and a separate terminal with
enhanced capabilities. Everything we're
going to use today will use the standard
terminal to be able to run these
particular programs. If you're a Windows
user, you're probably familiar with the
directory command or diir command. This
is a command that will list out all of
the files and the folders in a
particular directory. In Linux, the
command is the ls command for list
directory contents. And this will show
you all of the files, all of the
directories, and anything else that is
located in that particular subdirectory.
In my distribution, there's color coding
in the terminal. So, anything that is a
directory is listed in blue. Anything
that's archived is in red. And there are
other colors you may find for different
file types. You'll often find that there
may be hundreds or even thousands of
files inside of a single directory. And
using the ls command lists all of those
files and they scroll down the screen
before you're able to see anything go
by. One way that you can pageionate this
list of files is using the pipe and
using the more utility. So, when you use
the ls command and use a pipe, we're
going to send the output of the command
on the left through the utility that's
listed on the right. This will allow you
to hit the space bar to go from one page
to the other rather than having
everything scroll by at
once. In my Linux terminal, the default
prompt shows me the user that is
currently logged in. This username is
professor. Has an at sign and then it
shows me the name of this device. And in
this particular case, this Linux machine
is called Atlantis. To be able to run a
command, we'll run it where the cursor
is flashing at the end of that line. I'm
simply going to run the ls command, and
it will list out a number of files that
are in this directory. You can see that
this lists out a number of directories
in the bold blue color. And I do have a
single file in this directory known as
first.ext. There's also a number of
system directories on this computer that
we might want to look at. For example,
let's use the cd command to change
directory to a particular subdirectory.
And in this case, we'll choose the /var
/log directory. If I perform the same ls
command again, you'll notice there are a
number of different files located in
this directory. If we wanted to get more
detail about each one of these files, we
could use the ls command with the -la
option. This lists out all of the
information associated with permissions,
rights, and the ownership of these
files. You can see that this lists out a
lot of information and it scrolled by a
number of different pages. Instead of
having it scroll by, let's use that
ls-la command again and pipe it to the
more utility. And now it will show me
the first page. And at the very bottom,
it provides me with an option to show
more. I'll hit the space bar and it will
move to the next page. It prompts me
again for more because there's
additional information. We'll just keep
hitting the space bar until finally
we've moved through all of the different
pages of this
output. There's a lot of information
that is shown in this expanded view of
the ls command. You'll notice that our
file names are on the right side of the
screen and there's a lot of other
information that is shown in this
expanded view of the ls command. Later
in this video, we'll show you more
information about all of the details
that we see on this screen.
When you're working at a command prompt,
you may be moving back and forth around
a particular computer and you may not
have the luxury of having a lot of
detail at the prompt telling you what
your current directory is. Fortunately,
there is a command pwd which will print
the working directory. It displays the
current directory path so that you know
exactly what directory you're in when
you run any of these commands.
In this Linux distribution, it adds the
current working directory onto the
prompt on the terminal. This means that
we don't necessarily need to use the pwd
command, but if you'd like to confirm
that the information that's being shown
on your terminal really is accurate, we
can use pwd and hit enter. And you can
see that we are indeed in the /var /log
directory. In the Linux operating
system, you don't directly rename a
file. you instead move a file from one
name to another. To be able to do this,
we use the MV command to move that file.
The syntax for this command is to use
the MV command. The first parameter is
the source of what you're starting with,
and the second parameter is the
destination of what you would like to
rename this file or rename this
directory to. So, for example, if you
wanted to rename the file first.ext and
rename it to second.ext, text, you
simply use those with the mv command. At
our command prompt, I'm going to go back
to my home directory by simply typing in
cd and hitting enter. You could also
type in cd and use the tillday to
specify that you'd like to go back to
your home directory. If we do a pwd, you
can see that we are indeed in
/home/professor. And let's look again at
the files that we have in that
directory. We have a lot of different
directories inside of this folder, but
we also have a single file called
first.ext. Let's now rename that file by
using the mv command. We will specify
the source. In this case, that is
first.ext. And we would like to change
the name of this to be
second.ext. And we'll hit enter. Notice
that we don't get any type of response
at the prompt. It simply puts us back
where we were. If we use the ls command
again, notice that first.ext is no
longer listed in the files in this
directory, but we do have a
second.ext, which we've renamed from our
original first.ext
file. Sometimes you don't want to change
the name of a single file. You'd like to
create a duplicate of that file. On a
Windows computer, we would use the copy
command. In Linux, it's very similar. We
would use the CP command to copy a file.
And the syntax for CP is very similar to
the one we just used for the move
command where it is cp the source file
name and the destination file name. So
if you wanted to make another copy of
the second.ext file, you would use cp
second.ext and then use the file name
you would also like to have. In this
case, we'll call it
third.ext. Back at our Linux command
prompt, let's perform an ls. And we can
see there is a second.ext file that is
in this directory. If I perform an
ls-la, you can see the second.ext file
is here. And the file size for this text
file is
9,358 bytes. This will be important when
we look at the duplicate of this file.
And we will duplicate it with the cp
command. Our first file that we will use
will be second.ext. I'm going to type in
sec and hit the tab key. That tab
completion very similar to the tab
completion you have in Windows. It finds
whatever matches in this current
directory and simply completes what we
were typing. In this case, I would like
to copy the second.ext file to a file
name third.ext and we'll hit enter.
Notice again, we don't get any prompts
back. It simply puts us back at the
command line. And we'll type again
ls-la. Notice now that we still have
that second.ext file that's
9,358 bytes, but now we have another
file in this directory known as
third.ext. And it is also
9,358 bytes, which makes sense since it
is a duplicate of
second.ext. Just as we can copy a file
to create a new document, we can also
remove files with the rm command. This
will delete the files from the file
system. If you want to delete an entire
directory, you'll need to make sure the
directory is empty. We can override that
empty directory requirement by using the
rm command with the -ash r option and it
will delete a directory even if files
still exist in that
directory. Now that we've copied
second.ext to third.ext, let's now
remove the original file name. We will
use the rm command and we'll specify
second.ext and hit enter. Although
second.ext text was there previously. If
we perform that same ls, you'll see now
that second.ext is not in this folder.
But of course, we still have its copy
that we named
third.ext. As you've probably seen in
other operating systems, there are ways
to specify the rights and permissions
associated with a single file. In
Windows, you do this from the file
properties. In the Linux command line,
we do this using the chmod command,
which means we are going to change the
mode of a file system object. This means
that we can choose a file or directory
in our system and decide who's able to
read that file, write to the file, or
execute the file. Sometimes you'll hear
this referred to as octal notation, and
we will look at details of that notation
in just a moment. For each of the
objects in the file system, we can set
different rights and permissions if you
are the file owner or user of the file.
You can set different file permissions
if you're part of the group that is
associated with that file. And then you
can set permissions for everyone else.
This would be others or all in the Linux
operating system. This list of modes or
permissions associated with each of
these objects is what's listed in the
very first column when we perform an
ls-l. You can see that it has a number
of different columns. There are
different letters and dashes. And what
we want to do is break down all of those
different letters and sections to see
exactly what those refer to.
Let's look at one line of the ls output
to see more details about this chod
command. In this case, we're listing out
a number of permissions associated with
a file name called
script.sh. And you can see there are a
number of different letters associated
with those rights and permissions. We're
able to get those letters added by
running a chmod command with 744 across
the file name known as
script.sh. And this is the result of
running that chod command. Let's now
break down all of these different
columns and letters to determine what
this really means. Notice that there are
10 different characters that are
included in that set of rights and
permissions. The first column we'll look
at in a moment, but generally this is
one that will have a dash if this is a
file and it will have a D if it's a
directory. There are also other letters
you might see in that very first column
depending on the type of file object it
happens to be. For the purposes of the
chmod command, we're really most
interested with these next three groups.
And you can see that each of these
remaining characters is separated. Three
of those are for the user. Three are
associated with the group ownership and
three of these would be for everyone
else on the system. You'll also notice
that the owner of the file and the group
associated with the file are listed in
the output of the ls command. Those are
the two names that we can see in the
middle of this line. The first one is
the name of the user. In this case, the
username is professor. And the second
word that's next to it is the name of
the group that has been assigned to this
file. In this case, this file is part of
group staff. So if you're trying to
figure out who the user is, what group
they belong to, and who everyone else
might be, you can find all of that
information in the ls output associated
with that file name. If we look at the
last nine characters of that first
column, you can see that the first three
letters are assigned to the user
permissions. The middle three are
assigned to the group permissions, and
the last three are assigned to everyone
else on that system. Notice also that we
have numbers associated with each of
those. These are associated with the
chod command we previously ran. The
chmod command was 744 and this
correlates to the user is seven, the
group is four, and everyone else is also
four. You'll also notice that those
numbers are associated with a series of
permissions. So the number seven is
associated with read, write, and
execute. The number four is associated
with read only. You can see that those
permissions are listed in this table
along with the type of RW and X that you
would expect to see in that small box of
three characters. So if we used a chmod
command of 744, that means that the
owner has permissions relating to number
seven. Everybody in the group has
permissions for number four and everyone
else has also permissions that are
number four. If we break this out into
those permissions, you can see that the
user being seven is read, write,
execute. So we would expect to see RWX
in that box and we do. The group
permission is four. That means read
only, which means we would expect to see
R- dash and that is what we see in the
middle box. And since others is also
four, then it is exactly the same as
group with the R dash dash. This is the
way that we're able to see at a glance
what type of writes and permissions are
associated with the different files at
the command line. If we look at the
output from our previous command that we
ran, you can see all of the different
files and folders that are listed in my
home directory and you can see in that
first column that there are a number of
different rights and permissions for the
different documents in this folder. If
you're just learning about these
different permissions and those
characters that you see in that first
column, this may be a bit overwhelming.
But as you start to parse these out and
become more familiar with what they
might be, you'll find that it becomes
very second nature when you're looking
at one of these file listings. Although
up to this point, we've been talking
about the chod command and using it with
numbers, there are also letters that you
can use to designate what you would like
to change and what you would like to
modify it to. We'll look at those
options in just a moment. We've already
seen the chmod command with the 744
option and the name of the file name.
And since it's 744, that means that the
owner of this file or the user has read,
write, and execute permission. The group
that is associated with this file has
readon permission. And in this case,
everyone else on the system also has
readonly permission. As I mentioned, you
can also use letters to determine what
permissions you want to set. You can use
that chod command. The first letter
would be the section that you would like
to change. If you use the letter A, we
would be referring to all users on the
system. That means not the owner of the
file and not the group associated with
the file. It would be everyone else. We
would then specify the type of
permission we would like to set. If you
use the dash, that means it would be not
that permission. If you use a plus sign,
we would be adding that permission. And
lastly is the permission itself. If you
want to use R, it would be read, W would
be write, and X would be execute. So for
this chod command where we're performing
the chmod A-W to first.ext, we're
obviously referring to A, that would be
everybody or all users on this computer.
So everyone who is not the owner of the
file or anyone who's not in the group
associated with this file would be the A
designation. And with the -w, the dash
means that we would be removing a
permission. And the permission we're
removing is the write permission. So
chmod a-w for first.ext will remove any
write permissions that are currently set
for all users on the system. Here's
another example where we're using the
letters to designate the permissions.
We'll use the chmod U +X. If it's the U,
that means it's the user or owner of the
file. In this case, it's the script.sh
file. And if we're using the plus sign,
that means we're going to add a
permission. And in this case, we're
going to add the X permission, which is
the execute
permission. Let's change the permissions
of a single file and see what the
results of changing those would be to
the information that is shown in the ls
command. We will perform an ls-l. And
you can see that I do have a file in
this directory known as third.txt.
You'll notice that the owner of the file
is professor and the group that is
assigned to this particular file is the
group staff. Let's also look at the very
first column. You can see that there's
nothing in the first column which means
that it is not a directory. It's a file.
And you can see rwash is the very first
options here which means the owner of
the file can read and write to the file
but not execute what's in the file. The
second three are r- dash. That means
that everyone who is in the staff group
has read access to that file but does
not have right access to the file. And
then the last three are dash dash which
means everyone else on the system has no
access to the third.ext file. Let's look
at just the third.ext file by performing
an ls-l and specifying just that file.
Now let's make a change to that single
set of permissions. And let's say that
we would like to chod this file. And we
would like to use
764 as the permissions associated with
this file. And then we need to specify
the file name which is third.ext. If I
hit my up arrow twice, it will cycle
through the different commands that I
previously run. We're going to run the
ls-l third.ext command again. And you
can see that changes were made to the
permissions as compared to the ones that
we previously had for this file. If we
look at these, we can see that the first
three characters are RWX. That specifies
that the owner of the file can read,
write, and execute this file. We also
have the next three of RW- that means
that anyone who is in the staff group
can read or write to this file. And then
the last three are r- dash, which means
everyone else on this computer can
simply read what is inside of the
third.ext file. When you start working
with files, directories, and
applications on a Linux device, you will
certainly run into a situation where you
will need to modify the permissions of a
single file. And using the chmod command
gives you complete control over that
process.
In our discussion about the chod
command, we talked a lot about who the
owner of the file was and what group was
associated with the file. Obviously, we
can make changes to those as well. We
can change who the owner of the file
might be associated with and we can
change what group is associated with a
file or directory. You do this by using
the chown command. That is the change
ownership command. And that allows us to
make changes based on the owner and the
group. You'll notice for example that
you can change the name of the owner by
simply specifying the owner itself. And
if you would like to specify the owner
and the group, you can do all of it also
on the same command line. For example,
let's say that we've been working on
this text file which contains
documentation on our backup process. And
now that we've completed this document,
we would like to change ownership of
this document to be the backup user. In
the previous command, we saw that the
third.ext text file was owned by user
professor. Let's say that we'd like to
turn this file over to someone else so
that they would own the file and be able
to use it on their system. Let's say
that we would like to modify the owner
from professor to user Jack. To do that,
we would use the chown command. We would
specify the user we would like to change
this to. In this case, the username is
Jack and the name of the file is
third.ext. When we hit enter, you'll
notice that we get an error message
saying that the operation is not
permitted. That's because to change the
ownership of a file, we will need
elevated rights and permissions. In
Linux, the way that we do that is to use
the sudo command. We will then do
exactly the same command
ch and third.ext. And when we do that,
it will ask us for a password since we
are asking it to perform this function
with elevated rights. I've previously
used my administrator password, so it
used that password that was cached
earlier. If you've not used your super
user password in this command prompt
yet, it will first prompt you for that
password and then perform the command.
Now that we've run the ch own command,
we can use the ls command again and look
at what the differences are for the
third.ext file. And you can see now that
the permissions are the same, but the
owner of the file has changed to Jack.
We can see that it is still part of the
staff group. And obviously the file name
remains the same with
third.ext. If you'd like to change both
the name and the group at the command
prompt, you can specify them both in the
same ch command. So we'll run the sudo
with the chown option. In this case, I'm
going to change the name back to
professor and then we're going to put a
colon and specify the name of the group.
Let's say in this case that we would
like to move this file to be part of the
backup group and then we'll specify
third.ext and hit enter. Now if we
perform that same ls command, you'll
notice that we're back to professor as
owning the file. But you can see that
the group name is changed to the backup
group for the file third.ext.
Whenever we're troubleshooting a system
or simply working on a document, we may
want to look inside of the files on the
system to see if we can locate a
specific type of text. The command in
Linux that allows us to do that is the
GP command. This will search through one
or multiple files or folders to be able
to find specific text that may be
located in those documents. To use GP,
we obviously use the GP option at the
command line. We specify what text we
would like to find in these files and
then you would specify one or more file
names directly afterwards. So if you
wanted to search for a particular file,
we would use the GP command. We would
specify the text we were looking for. In
this case, the text is the word failed.
And the name of the file we would like
to hunt through is o.log. This could be
a very large document, but you'll find
that the GP command works very quickly
to find this information. So if we use
that at the command line, it will list
out every line inside of that o.log file
that contains the word
failed. Let's use the gp command for the
third.ext file. You can see that there
are
9,358 bytes inside of this file. So
instead of listing through every single
line that happens to be in the file and
try to look for the text we want, we can
simply use the gp command. In this case,
I'm going to look for the word launch.
And the name of the file name is
third.ext. And you can see that there
are three separate lines inside of this
very big file that contains the words
launch. In this case, it is a
GDM- environment that is listed. But
since we did specify the word launch, it
finds it wherever it happens to be
inside of that
document. The Linux file system contains
thousands and thousands of files. And if
you're looking inside of a users's
directory, you may have no idea where a
particular file may be located.
Fortunately, the Linux operating system
includes a utility that helps you find a
file and you can find it listing the
name or the extension. This find command
has a number of different options. You
can use simply find by itself if you're
in a current directory and looking for a
specific file type, or you can specify
what directory you would like to use
along with a number of other different
search parameters. In our home
directory, we know on this system there
happens to be a file named third.ext.
But let's say that we just logged into
this system. We've never been on this
computer before and we would like to see
if there's more instances of files that
are named third something. So, we're
going to use the find command. I'm going
to use this with the parameter third.
And since I would like to find the word
third and any extension associated with
that, I'm going to use a dot and an
asterisk to specify a wild card. When we
hit enter, it will search through this
directory and all directories underneath
to find all of the matching files. And
in this case, there's only one
third.ext. Let's make this a little bit
broader in our search so that we can
really see the power of the find
command. In this case, I'm going to use
the find command and search for any file
that may be in my current directory or
directories underneath that has a
capital letter D and then anything else
afterwards. And if we hit enter, you can
see that any file or folder that has the
first letter as a capital D is now
listed inside of my local user
directory.
If you've ever started Windows after
something like a power outage or an
inadvertent power down, then you notice
that it goes through a process of
checking the logical file system before
it starts the OS. You can also perform a
similar function in Linux using the file
system check utility or
fsk. This utility will check for any
logical file system errors. If it finds
any inconsistencies in file sizes, it
will correct those and it will look for
any files that may not be included in
the file system index. This check
commonly runs during the startup process
because it needs to check the file
system before it is mounted as part of
the OS. You can see that it goes through
the process of checking all of the files
and clusters that are in a particular
mounted directory. And you can see it
goes through each one, checks all of
them to make sure that they're working
properly. and then continues with the
normal bootup
process. When your Linux system starts
up, it begins adding different folders
into the file system using the mount
utility. You can also run this utility
yourself at the command line to view
what folders may already be mounted. And
if you would like to manually mount or
unmount a folder, you can also use the
mount command for that. This is very
similar in functionality to the Windows
net use command, although the mount
functionality is more integrated into
the Linux OS. If you simply run the
mount command with no parameters, it
will list out all of the mount points
that are currently set and running on
your system. This might be a large list
to parse through. So, if you're looking
for something specific, you may want to
pipe this to the GP command to try to
find exactly a piece of text that you're
looking for. One common use of the mount
command is to make the information
available on a USB drive that you've
just connected to your Linux computer.
Most modern versions of Linux will
recognize that you plugged in a USB
device and it will automatically mount
that USB drive. But if your system has
been modified or doesn't provide a way
to automatically mount that, then we'll
need to use the mount command to be able
to use that USB drive.
Let's look at all of the different mount
points that are currently on my Linux
system. There are quite a few here. So,
I'm going to scroll back up. We can see
that when I started the mount command,
it showed us that the CISF fs has been
mounted to /is in our file system. Proc
is mounted to the /proc mount point.
UDEV is mounted to /dev. Dev PTS is
mounted to /dev/pt.
temp fs is mounted to slashrun and so
on. You can see there's quite a number
of mount points and on your Linux
distribution you'll probably have a
large number of mount points as
well. Earlier in this video we ran the
ch own command to be able to change the
ownership or group of a particular file
object. To be able to run that command,
however, we needed elevated access. And
you notice that we ran the sudo command
to execute that command as the super
user. There are also options in the sudo
command to run that command as a
different user ID who's on that system
as well. Sudo allows us to run a single
command with that elevated access. But
you might want to run all commands with
that elevated access. To be able to
become super user at your command
prompt, you use the su command. By using
just su, you're changing the entire
terminal session to one that is a super
user session. Any commands that you type
in in this super user terminal session
will run with elevated rights and
permissions. When you're finished
running as the super user, you can use
the exit command and that will put you
back into the normal prompt for that
terminal screen. From a best practices
perspective, we would much rather run
sudo to be able to run these commands
rather than starting a single terminal
screen that has complete access to the
system. Here's another example of
someone running a command with elevated
rights and permissions. They're using
the sudo option and running the shutdown
command to be able to shut down this
particular computer. Shutdown is one of
those commands that is not available to
users that are on the system. You need
to be the super user to be able to run
that shutdown
prompt. There are a number of different
ways to install and update applications
on your Linux device. Many distributions
use the apt command to do this. This is
the advanced packaging tool. And from
there, you can install, remove, or
update any of the packages or
applications that you've installed on
your system. For example, if you wanted
to install a copy of the Wireshark
protocol analyzer, you would use the
sudo with a use install option and
specify
Wireshark. Let's install Wireshark on my
Linux distribution. We use the sudo
command with apt. We're going to install
Wireshark and we'll hit enter. Because I
am running the sudo option, it asked me
for my password. I'm going to type that
in. Hopefully, I got that right. I did
because now it begins the process of
determining what it needs to install
along with Wireshark to be able to get
this working. It says that it needs to
get 70.1 megabytes of archives. And
after this operation, we'll be using 282
MGB of additional disk space. Do I want
to continue? Yes, I do. I'll hit enter.
And it's going to go through the process
of downloading all of the documents that
it needs, installing the application,
and then putting me back at the command
prompt. With most applications, it runs
through that at the command line and
it's done. In the case of Wireshark,
there are additional options that I need
to choose. It tells me that I need to
configure some options within Wireshark.
Should nonsupervisors be able to capture
packets? In this particular case, since
this is my computer, I'm going to say
yes. And then it continues with the
installation process. This usually only
takes a few minutes for most
applications. It goes through and
updates the applications running on your
system. And then it tells you that
everything is up to date. No services
need to be restarted. No containers need
to be restarted. No user sessions are
running outdated binaries and no VM
guests are running outdated hypervisor
binaries on this host. And now if we go
to the main menu of my Linux
distribution, we can type in Wireshark
and it finds Wireshark as an option that
we can run on our desktop now that we've
installed it with the apt
option. In Linux, there are many
different ways to perform similar
functions and some of those will differ
between different distributions. For
example, your distribution may not have
the apt utility. Instead, it may be
using a similar utility known as DNF.
That is an abbreviation for dandified
yum. This is an upgrade to the yum
package manager for Linux. And this is
another utility that allows us to
install, update, or remove packages from
our computer. If you've been using
previous Linux distributions and you're
already familiar with yum. Yum stands
for the yellow dog updator modified,
then you're going to be very familiar
with the syntax for DNF. You will
usually find DNF used on systems that
use the Red Hat package manager or RPM
to install applications. So if you're
trying to install an application and you
find that the apt command is not
available, then you're probably using a
Linux distribution that uses DNF.